self-proclaimed EU supergirl Maddalena k
is here to make some noise outside the
houses of parliament in London her arch
enemy is brexit brexit was a non-issue
for me I didn't think it was going to
happen so when I woke up on the 24th of
June and I was like whoa how come so
many people think that this is a good
idea the shock was so great she decided
to give up her studies now she's a
full-time activist for Europe the EU is
about love and peace and tolerance and
these are values that we should
celebrate even a sporting injury won't
deter Supergirl she thinks the future of
her country is in danger you know there
wasn't a manifesto and until we get the
final brexit deal and we see what the
reality of Rexie is and how that matches
up to what was promised people still
don't know what they voted for about the
EU we want to stop brexit there are a
lot of people that just don't care we've
got to make them care so I might go and
grab some there are currently more
supporters than opponents but it's a
narrow lead
slight change but not a big one because
people haven't really been thinking
about this but I think you know as we
get closer when we get through the
summer I get to October people will be
thinking about it seeing the risks the
country is divided most of the probe
wrecks eaters are of the older
generation and it's been a very
expensive project had two failed one at
that
no no yeah it's like a football result
you didn't like the result well tough I
think the people have made their vote
that say they should stick to it but a
Super Girl doesn't give up so easily her
message is well-received by young people
have they told you about the marching
leaves or the if we can make the
movement big enough it would be worth
stopping it if we can we want to stop
wrecks it we think that it's gonna be
terrible
Madalena wants a second referendum on
Britain's EU membership but even her
fellow brexit opponents aren't sure if
we to say we're overturning brexit these
people who voted for breaks that already
have a genuine distrust in the system
they don't believe it's working for them
they're gonna be angry anyway even if
you know if brexit happens and they
don't and they don't see an improvement
in the quality of life I think there's
going to be anger and resentment
whatever exhausted but happy with 70
signatures it's been a success
[Music]
a lot of people particularly social
media will say to me you know like I
give them hope and inspiration through
my art and my music and sort of give
them the drives that they need to carry
on as well in a country that's so
divided over brexit Matt Lena Kane Mike
really meet some kind of super power to
make her dream of staying in the EU a
reality